[Music]
hello and welcome to another night of
chess on psychology if you are
an american or in america happy turkey
week hope you're ready to give some
thanks
uh
if not
and you're not in u.s and you don't have
a holiday or a day off well
still
in the u.s to celebrate it so
grab a turkey sandwich
i just had a very very fun stream with
dennis barra sitting in the back hiding
in the corners
make sure to check that out on his
channel chessweebz
twitch it was we did the tournament we
gave up a
book or two we had a nice um
code
that you might also be able to use if
you get there in time
so check it out
hopefully the code still works
all right um
so what we're going to go today and do
is the continuance of the same sicilian
series that we started probably for the
rest of the year that's what we're going
to do
um today we're going to talk about javen
again
and
it's not going to be too weird
like some of the videos that we did
earlier but some of them are going to be
um because foreign there's so many
transposition it can you can start from
con palestine you can start from night
or if you can start from
god knows with asics
so a lot of different things can still
lead there so i want you to still be
careful and whoa
no no no evaluation bars it's the last
thing i want
no
yeah no bismuth hairs there we go
so um yeah basically i want you to be
able to
think your best and give your best
but these are some of the it's more of a
suggestion of some of the ones that i
point and i recommend
so by no means if you play anything else
don't feel obligated to follow what i
play all right
without further ado let's see the chat
the chat is ready
oh
and alex hackworth
became a member of the
saint louis chess club today
congratulations
welcome
all right
let's go
and how do i kill this noise
i guess that'll do it
nah kill it there we go
okay
um
so first thing i want to show you is the
transposition to chevening and
chaveningen is when there is like the e6
and d6 what if they start off with
e6 so
with we gets the position here now
we talked about
uh composing which was with a6 last week
we talked about this weird sicilian
fortnight the week before that so you
have those options to look for
what if opponent plays um
not khan slash
not the streaming
schiveningen oh my god
could i
mispronounce that any worse
all right um
so
now i want to first show you one game
that i played this is just a very very
very brief introduction to bishop d3 do
not just go play bishop d3 because i
showed it you still got to work a lot on
it
my main recommendation is with knight c3
but bishop d3 is also pretty cool
and this is how i did it
i really like this pawn structure the
maroxy bind pawn structure i did on
another video on it which i recommend
for you to go watch
but with this marx vine that's very nice
because when you get knight c3 and you
get this bishop ass rook c1
it's very um comfortable especially
since this bishop is on e7 on g7 that
can cause some issues
so i enjoyed it
and to be fair this was kind of
preparation
so i knew what my opponents played i
prepared and i
whooped them
so
let me ask you what do you think how do
you think the middle game is going to
look so what do you think are some of
the things that white wants to do is all
the things that black wants to do
so what do you think is happening right
now
i have in-person audience i have
in computer audience oh chess of stupids
say i'm a medical student too there so
well good for you send me a dm we can
compare notes
there's going to be a lot of pieces ah
don't deny that
white wants to point the queen side i
guess not wrong but i could simply just
want to
[Music]
like keep the queen slide occupied while
i do what i want in the king side
so
it could be one of the big things i want
to do as well
nobody in person
feels
there's a lot of fingers on the noses so
this is a nice pose
do i hear a very large blender
or leaf blower yeah
like
is the opening name after a tournament
like i believe so because i know that
the person cheven engine did exist
pretty strong player too
so
well there will be a contest for d4
you're not drunk yeah
what else do you guys
um i'm not opposed to b4 and stuff
i agree don't allow d4 yeah yeah so
opponents might want to play d5
so we don't want to allow that i
completely agree with that
what else do you got
so
it's so quiet here
come on give me something
what do you want to do as white
yeah so that's kind of the thing do you
want bishop e3 or you want b3 bishop b2
do you think you're going to want to
play a four later or do you think you're
going to want to just keep the queen
king side steady
i see a gm in the dark
trying
all right
so
um yeah i went for kingish one my idea
was i just want to go f4 soon
technically f4 works right now bishop v3
works right now i feel like a part of me
is happy with this as well but i think
english one with idea f4 is a little bit
easier now we don't want to give
opponent any type of
happiness that way so
that's what we're going to go for
all right
let's say now black goes for bishop c6
they're getting ready to play d5 they
want to take this what do you think we
should do
i'm very curious on the status of the
leaf blower
what time is that at 7 pm
i agree
so
i see the chat is
still warming up
possible i'm not opposed to it
knight will have to go back to a6
then what would you do
no
i'm also reading the chat the chat is
more fan of like bishop f3 ideas rather
than a3 i'm fine with a3 to be honest
you can continue defending this pawn 83
is nice the only the only downside is
opponent wants to do knight c5 so it
might force you to exchange it just be
aware of that
okay so
bishop f3 queen b6
now what do we do
i can still try for a3
still gotta develop these pieces
i guess this trick is all right where it
is but
all right
so i went to the game i went for queenie
too it's a
blunder to be fair don't do it i was
cutting myself
again to be fair this is uh eight years
ago so
um
robert levi
if i was um
invited to do that and i was fairly
compensated maybe maybe someday not this
year
all right
yeah queenie two was just a
mistake
um knight d4 was better but i didn't
want to keep moving at night so i just
um
ignored his existence and my opponent
used it it hurt a little to be honest
and now opponent should have actually
went and started the fight for this file
but they didn't
and
now i should have done this but i didn't
i told you this was a this is a game why
queens is a mistake because i gave up
that
uh that that
peace activity
my opponent just got so um
got a lot easier for them to breathe
you don't want to address this person by
name
my problem is i'm not sure how to
pronounce it one two three four five six
seconds
not this
anybody
wanna help me out no i just wanted you
to read out the sequence of numbers oh
yeah
oh then not the opponent's name the chat
okay i got it that makes more sense now
i'm not supposed to say my opponent's
name just
can't say it
all i know is that this was in
um
world huge
2013
oh i might be completely wrong too
that's what i have in my memory
this is this sounds like a 2013 version
of me so
um
let's go for that
anyway so i went bishop v3 and i finally
have advantage but
let's face it
opponent is still playing decent
now
i'm no longer going to be doing stuff in
the king side
per se because so many things are
happening in the coin side what do you
think we want to do
right now
i see a bishop d2 i see a rook f a1
what else you got
i see children cafe once what's the deal
with rk1 what am i missing
i see a kg one
am i getting troll
feels like it's
all right
um i very much would prefer to be able
to eat this queen so if anybody can help
me in that
quest gets a gold star
turkey sandwich
the iron is that i keep hyping about
thanksgiving but
um i had initially planned to spend
thanksgiving in two different people's
houses
so
one for lunch one for dinner
and then last minute my passport stuff
got fixed and i was like you know what
i'm gonna book it flight to london go
see my brother and my mom so that's what
i was gonna do
so i'm actually flying out tomorrow
morning i'll be back tuesday so we'll
still have this next week but
yeah
things just apparently i can be very
spontaneous some people think that's
good some people think that's bad but
very good plat
i'm very good at last minute plannings i
don't lose my cool but
people people can't really handle it
okay this is not a therapy session
so
not yet we might get there on to it
um
so what do you think
okay
somebody said meowdi is that a howdy but
saying a meowthy
yes
ah i should use that on people
all right nine day two nights and then
you're just gonna go for the night just
chill have a little horse meet wait
sorry that was bad
it's weird because nights is nights but
in any other language it's horse
so
i was going for the blood of the night
but i tried to anyways
let's let's pretend i never said that
but
anywho
oh sorry ben simon good luck cutting
that out
okay so we're just gonna eat some um
pieces let's go but fair
um
and the rest of the game was relatively
easy because i have an extra piece i'm
fairly
confident when i have extra material
especially a full piece and i don't
really have any
attack on my king
so this was a nice
nice game for me i just increased
pressure and my opponents eventually
broke under pressure
and they resigned
so
of course
if you choose to play bishop d3 here
there is no guarantee that that will
happen for you
but
um
i just kind of want you to be aware of
that option
to be fair there's a lot of options with
with queenside castling that we're not
really going to pay much attention to
there are so many many
weird cool lines with g-force here
geforce there
push pawn there and neither in polson
i'm not trying to go for like a super
computer move i will still want to um
introduce some lines for you that you
will be comfortable playing with or
without an engine
so we're not gonna talk about there's
those are way more on
uh night orbs when you have like luxury
ones or g4s or
god knows what so those i'm just going
to say that they exist
so that you can
um be aware of that
but i'm not gonna
give myself a aneurism talking about
them all right so knight c3 my opponents
um
if you want more a6 if you want more c6
look at last week's but today we're
going to talk about d6 now
after d6 i usually like to go bishop v2
because i feel like at this point i'm a
little committed when i play knight c3
and in this specific game
my opponents went through bishop e7 and
i castled now what if they went for a6
let's talk about that
we're going to talk about it really
quickly but if a6 it can easily
transpose you can cast them you can play
bishop e3
you can do g4 now standard crazy g4
stuff out there
and
after that
um
knight d7
this is what happened in the game i was
actually just recommending this idea to
one of my students today so hey if
you're watching you know i'm not kidding
when i recommend
i was recommending it as black though
well
it's kind of annoying to be fair
um
they're b4s they're eateries i always
like a4 because it gives me more
opportunities to
mess around with the opponent's queen
side or fix it so then i can start doing
stuff in my
side of the board now
what if b4 let's talk about that
because if b4 you move the knight and
what if the what if you lose this
what would you do then
yes i i agree in chaveningen g4s might
be too nice
sometimes
so
anybody i see a bishop of three
fair point
i see knight c6s why knight c6 is being
recommended
all right so i'm not opposed to
f3 but taking on b4 is another one rook
c3 could be another one
so
i'm kind of
more fond of
maybe knight b4 immediately rather than
bishop f3 because we should have three
opponents can go bishop b7 it also takes
away my knight c6
possibilities
oh brian clark is gonna start playing
budapest because of me and my brother
more credit goes to my brother for that
one just saying
because
he's the one who did most of the
the idea and the analysis for that
he likes crazy openings
he's such an engine engine boy
there's not a phrase like this there's a
mama's boy but there's not an engine's
boy i wonder i want to introduce that to
chess language
people who just continuously just click
space when they're dealing with engine
that's the engines boy
is that like
is a farsi term or something no i just
came up for you
i'm being too creative also there's too
much spirits of holiday around me
all right
engine andy oh that's interesting
oh yeah i did want to mention that there
is a success too yeah pretty
pretty happy for the kid
okay
okay we're getting sidetracked
so
if not before if take
then you have the option of
actually taking or takes a four
attacking this guy
if they take you do not need 240 because
now you can simply take back haha
now let's go back
if bishop b7 now you can try to i want
to say protect it as needed
but i'm also a little skeptical i don't
want to give up
options here
i really also want to eat this so i get
the passport already so that's
that's um
that's as much as there is for it
okay
um
so i just wanted to introduce the idea
of a6b5 i think you're
well informed on the existence of this
line now
all right so how about just bishop e7
castle
now
what if start with knight c6 then what
do we do
to to be fair blacklist does want to get
a lot of a6 possibly queen c7 castle now
sometimes they do an ic6 sometimes to do
97 so
that's kind of the next few moves
because sometimes they might want to get
the bishop out from this way so they
need to play b5 sometimes they want to
get it out this way so they go
with that so there's a lot of different
ideas and shivaning and black can do so
it's kind of important for you to know
all of them
then you can like transpose between them
that okay so now black wants this now
black ones that how do i how is this
position different
i'm getting bishop e3's in the chat
oh ben your favorite um
your favorite viewer is back
all right it's a visual tree let's say
the castle
and let's go bananas let's go f4 oh
bananas
small
small
spoiler alert if you do go back and
watch the stream that i did the chesweep
aka dennis bars there was a part about
bananas and jalapenos just don't don't
mix them up that's that's the only thing
i'm gonna say just
yeah just don't mix them up
okay
first things first what if e5 because
this is the only line that we would get
without a6
what if e5
are we going to take it are we going to
push move the knight
any suggestions
need to cough
earlier
i don't think i i'm built for that
my voice hurts my throat hurts
all right so some people want knight
takes e6 go for it
they take back you can take they can
take
and you can exchange um queenie one is a
possibility too to keep the queens in
this specific game i was
fine with i was playing a team event and
the team was fine with
a solid result so
that's what i went for and i exchanged
queens and i just wanted to play risk
less game
surprisingly i ended up with the i'm not
surprisingly but this kind of feels like
um the placement of my pieces kinda
feels like four nights so i was getting
a small deja vu and i really liked it
so
yeah
this was this was going well
i'm gonna
go through the
yeah right the pawns are pretty pretty
not good anymore for black i'm gonna
briefly just go through it to show you
the game in case
you're so curious to know how this game
ended
alright
now f5 yeah or nay
if you like f5
well why do you like f5
i got an a
fair point
opens up the king i don't think the king
is that
important at the time being
you'd prefer to keep e4 as a target fair
point but so are you assuming that i'm
going to take it just right now
somebody says good move i guess
well
um let's see
what if i take this first
and then simply activate this little guy
i was so close to making another horse
joke i think two at the in a row would
be too
too much anyways
um in farsi it's asp ass literally means
horse what am i supposed to do i always
see it as a horse not a knight
do you guys like well when it's imagined
do you
do most people actually imagine like a
night night or just like a horse
do you picture humans on the horse or
just the horse
yes
thank you
i think this this calls for pull
um
but yeah
stop horsing around that's a good one
yeah
yeah
like detroit is pretty nice oh wait
i don't know like this just hit me like
there was us um
probably most of you haven't watched it
but um like disney came out with this
weird tangle tangling tangled movie the
the cartoon animation and it was funny
because there was a horse in it and at
the end the horse does actually become a
knight so
now they have a dilemma
oh way too much fun
okay
93
let's say knight goes away to defend
these then what do you do
but how did i not win this
oh my god i think i'm gonna say i want
it and let's just move on to another
game
um
no this was okay let's just talk about
this
so in the game i took okay maybe that's
why then when it's i should have started
with this
go for e5 not c5
oh my god they're serious to go for c5 i
didn't go for c5 so why am i self
sabotaging
yeah this would have been a nice setup
you can start with c42 anyways
um
in the real game i simply went for take
take and i took there first
and i'm giving some of the advantage
away wait no i'm not
ah but now
okay how am i how on god's blue earth am
i supposed to put around this yeah
wait why did you give it away
okay so far so good
i don't think my rookie five was wise
well i could have just kept the tension
but then take take
comes over here wants to eat these
yeah but opposite colored bishops it's
usually is a draw but when it comes to
rooks the when there is a
rook there it might make it a little bit
more pleasant but yeah i didn't really
um
do that beautifully to keep this
position float
so i was hoping for a weird blender
hey i try
right
so
it ended as a draw
yeah
but that's the thing you it's not about
the material when it comes to the
specific end games it's also about the
fact that you can't advance your
position and the sad part is even if i
do
erase all of this this king is in the
wrong
corner
because
if my bishop was a different colored
bishop that would have worked because i
could have eventually given its king a
check and pushed and promoted the pawn
but
yeah
yeah
there wasn't one point that i would be
like yeah here was a blunder it wasn't
like that it i gradually gave up the
advantage but the the rook the um what
up one is king got active it was already
the end of it
here opponent already has a good um
grasp on the position perhaps my
exchange could have ah but i kind of had
to
maybe should d6 pick this up
instead this is very tricky
it was a draw how old was i when i
played this game this was i think um
five or six years ago
so
teenager let's go with that all right
i'm gonna switch gears we talked about
this e5 we're gonna go then talk about
asics now before we do that i do want to
talk about a6 now
ah
because this a6 wait
first
no
no here a6 because there is a6 with
knight c6 there's a6 without knight c6
so i think it's important to know
either of them
and be prepared against both of them
so
all right
um
it's was a totally winning end game
i wouldn't say winning i had an
advantage but converting it to a full
win it would have been very difficult
and
if you find a way do leave it in the
comments below i'd be very happy about
that
all right
so a6 what do we do
well that's a weird question because we
can do f4 we can division b3 we have a
lot to do so i don't think that's a fair
question to ask i like this f4 idea i
played with e bishop e32 it kind of
transposes
unless opponent wants to do early big
fights without castling
so
all right now let's talk about this one
opponent is proposing a knight exchange
yay or nay are you gonna take that
i see a lot of
nays cool
also thank you for the explanation clown
shell chemist
was that supposed to be a coach
chemist several times today
i have no idea not i don't know it's
just a shell chemist i don't know
anything about this person i played with
them
oh you played them today yeah ah yeah
oh wait
no i can't
was gonna ask like con contemporant
crystal no it's from pennsylvania he's
not we don't know oh yeah
mystery of the day
to get pi on it
all right
what do you think
oh thank you deep
probably should have continued saying it
but i struggled pronunciating it in my
head i'm going to give it a try
for stare i'm unhorrible with names i
feel like
a new name for me
it's
small by now near zenforming
okay so what do you think
you're gonna take it you're going to
play bishop e3
you're going to play bishop e3
the idea is to have to take you can
simply take back
and now there's this queen g3 this is
all theory
white is better now
tell me why why do you think white is
better right now
there's a leading development fair point
how about the pawn structure painting
with pawn structure
where king is safer that's also
partially true
well i guess right now there's some
ideas on it so the thing is here
um
the best move what do you think is the
best move
where is a free pawn
ah now we're talking ah now we're
talking there you go yep queen g7 would
be the best move yes
if take simply move the king away
if recreates now you take over here if
they take you take
and you're attacking this guy if it goes
f8 you got bishop h5
if
let's see
bishop goes e6 you can still go bishop
h5 to be fair
bishop is five here is even better
a little weird i know
and if truck tries to go to f8 then you
can take it's not you kind of forced to
strike a fade
and now
you get to win
another piece if they let you obviously
so
there's a lot of little
ideas about just because they take you
don't have to take back so i think
that's a very important part of chess to
be aware of just because your opponent
does something doesn't mean you have to
let them take the lead
wait
now that feels like i'm talking about
tango taking the lead
i've actually never danced angle i kind
of want to but not many places here to
go do classic dances i know there's a
salsa place around here but i guess
that's the extent of it
alright
um yeah i just wanted to mention this
queen g7 because i played a game and i
missed it
so i just want you to be aware that
that's there and it still hurts me
but
all right
so this was this other e6 idea with e5
that i wanted to mention now let's talk
some shop
about
now a6 okay
now this is a big line most likely we're
gonna spend most of next week talking
about seven engine two
and then we're going to do a smooth
transition to nidorf which will probably
take another two weeks
beer
so what do you think we should do right
now opponent just played a6 they do want
to go b5
so you have options you can stop it
immediately you can let it happen
there is with knight c6 there is with
knight d7 for knight d7s we will talk
more about them next week
because i want to be able to actually
have enough time to go over the
differences
but i want you to be aware of their
existence
how big of a skill gap between iem and
regular gm
good one
i don't know how to answer that because
it's really depends on the age the time
availability the
the skills are they actually trying to
improve are they just you know happy
where they are don't have other life
things to do so it really depends
but i guess the answer of about 100
points
is the best one
um
i don't think that it's impossible force
for
one im to become a gm
but
that was a good answer i'm still going
to use that
um
getting a gm or so they're a little
harder just the i don't think the rating
improvement is as hard as getting the
norms because
when i was trying to get my norms for
just wim it was so annoying because like
for a good three months i'd play
tournaments and every single tournament
i was so close and it was just would not
happen one tournament one opponent
wouldn't show up so it would be like a
eight round norm one tournament i would
have a like a country trouble because
you know like you need different
certain number of countries three four
three plus countries
one tournament i would have a great
performance but
weird um titles of the opponents was not
enough so every tournament was just
something same for a the gym i had less
troubles but so it's like you have to be
able to actually
um
have that skill but you need luck too
you need to actually play in tournaments
that there are enough players
people will actually show up to their
games they're enough titled players
there's enough countries
it's a lot of stuff
all right
where were we we're talking about
whether we want to play a4 or nuts
i liked a4 now with shivening and there
are multiple things one can do there is
this weird well i don't want to say
weird because i realize i see weird too
much
there is this idea that you can follow
with
move the king bring the bishop there's
this like g4 line that you can go for
but
um there are other things as well
um so for example
in this specific game
opponents went for bishop d7
there are other possibilities too bishop
d7 is definitely not the only one
for example queen c7
queen c7 you can still go for
this idea
i like this little knight b3 sneaky
and
then
g4
as promised
now my idea is i want to be able to push
this
knight away
and follow it with a bishop g2 and bring
my queen there
this is a nice attack especially in
lower ratings because for black it can
get really hard to hold so that's one of
the lines that i do recommend especially
for lower
less skilled
players lower
lower rated slash less skilled players
so that's one thing
i'm going to show you how my game
finished so i was actually like 2000
rated player 2013
and
my opponent was like 170 points more
than me
and i still got to whoop him
very short
very short
game too
uh when you're doing this attack because
you start this attack with pawns it's
very important to find some time to
include other pieces too because if
you're just pushing pawns well
that's not really optimal
so it's very important to
find time to do that
no no more queen h5s but i still want to
be able to get my queen to maybe h4
now queen e1 for h4 would be ideal but
knight takes c2 exists so i have to
improvise
okay i did the improvision provision
yeah
and now opponents knight c5 would have
been a little better d5 would be better
because i'm trying to to create an
attack in the king size the best thing
opponent can do is make a mess in the
center
but opponents
delayed that
and
now e5 question yay or nay
and if you say nay what do you think
would have been a better idea
whooping
ah that's good
gmp she is home yeah i'm a little upset
that i have to leave the little guy
behind again but i have one of my
friends who's going to actually sleep at
my place because peachy is such a
mommy's boy
he does not sleep alone
he just he just doesn't if you don't
come home in time he will not sleep
and he'll just be behind the window and
i hate doing that to him
so i um i actually asked one of my
friends if she could have peachy for a
few days or wouldn't mind sleeping in my
house and she agreed so i'm not worried
about peachy
i'll miss him dearly
though all right
so the answer for e5 was that a year in
a
a lot of people are saying d5 i agree
very much you're right on the right
track because then this is a hole that
opponent knight can jump in
if i try to
go away knight of f8 and i don't really
have that much of an attack
so
yeah have to be very careful
opponents
chose wrong they went for e5 now how can
i um
punish them i guess teach them a lesson
i guess that's a better way
probably at
five possibly
but the bishop g5 we have to you have to
you have to make
you have to take notes of that
uh there's someone to say rook thank you
seven i think that's a little too early
how about something just chill just
queenish four slow threat and checkmates
when they play
if they play knight fa then go for f5
now if they take you can still
activate your pieces you can still want
to take over here
you can still
let's say if they take this move
actually this is a good question what
would you do right now
my first thought was just like rook f1
but i guess rkf1 might not work as well
so what do you think it's a good idea
for whites rights now
oh somebody's think
wow that's very fast
what am i kicking on there here
we talked about kicking opponents
streaming dennis i think i'm imagining
things though
all right knight d4 would be very nice
actually
surprise surprise the idea is if you
take bishop can take and that's gonna be
a wrap
and
so my opponent didn't take up my
opponent didn't find knight f8 they
played h5 now i played f5 careful and
busan doesn't work your queen falls
they went bishop away now what do you
think we should do you definitely have
advantage
ambassador is forced
wait what now
what am i missing
oh in the previous position now poison
is not a forced move this is not
checkers
flight checkers i don't like it when
they force you
how about just simple moves obviously
rook f1 might also be a good idea
but bishop f3 seems like a good start on
its own
if d5
now boom
boom
boom
voila
come on
that was such a good point of stop
this is waiting just let me win already
oh yeah i was right the opponent did
resign after i took here
okay that's how i remembered but um in
the and i can post analysis this would
have been a
fun way to end too
all right i got one more line that i'm
gonna cover real quick
uh i'm gonna scroll a big one back that
wasn't as big as i thought it would be
so instead of queen c7 what if bishop d7
now i kind of like knight b3 because i
want to avoid takes
i had this opponent which kind of chased
my knight
uh that's kind of that's all right um
but i played very poorly taking is not a
good choice i think e5 would have been
better just because of take take knight
d5 you take tank
say take first
yeah this is black is still alright
white is not
winning or anything it's a tiny bit of
advantage
but that's what i should have gone for i
made a mistake of just taking i played
it too easy
and
i
somehow messed it up very royally very
royally
yeah
yeah
why do you want to avoid the trade
he played knight b3
oh
because like uh
my main game is going to be in the king
side so it's much easier for me to
um
fix kinks in my other side queen side
and center and just make sure that
opponent doesn't have much threats there
so if i can fix that slide then i can do
whatever i want in the king side
so for example here when i played knight
b3 well if i leave the knight to be i
always have to wait for them to take it
i always have to wonder about possible
um
the pins
i might have to wonder about
different ideas so take putting the
knight on b3 you can't really do much
about this side at the moment
you still have d5 e5 options to prepare
for example right now e5 might be nice
too
so
does that answer it maybe okay cool
so i went knight b3 they were if knight
a5 and i just kind of messed it up
very fast
what was g4
i don't i don't understand what was i
doing here this was not my game i
disowned this game
fake news
all right i did not do this
i actually did unfortunately then i lost
like a little baby
okay so after knight a5
instead of e5 would have been nice but i
messed up
instead of knight a5 what if opponent
goes queen c7 now here you can do a5 you
can still go for g4 stuff i trust you
with g4 stuff and i just developed that
way
now e5 here was
felt a little too
rushed
and
this felt alright
um now i'm talking a lot about the gut
feeling instead of an engine i realized
that
but
d5 might have been a little bit more
challenging after e5 knight goes away i
have a lot of decisions to make what to
push what not to push so
i think that would be
um
nice to figure out
but anyways in the game opponent to e5 i
went f5 and then i went g5
might be this was a little too fast
take tank and opponent on drook d
eight
um
possibly the other rook might have been
better to open up the room for
bishop going back to f8
so keep that in mind
for example this could have happened see
i'm attacking in the king side so
opponent has to do stuff in the center
on difference notes if not at the other
rook went there i have no idea why i
played this move
i truly don't know
i'm not winning this game but it was
such a torturous game
um the better but better idea would be
just to do rook f2 if you're trying to
defend this all right defend it that way
or just take first
and then just go to rook f3
just go all the way in
right
commit to the whole thing
the other idea
could be maybe
whoops
could be
let's see if i don't want to take it if
i still want to keep the goodies
can i play
i mean i guess why i played drug c1
because i truly wanted to free up my
queen but now applying its d5 i opponent
didn't play this d5 so i was fine
but this d5 is very
crucial for opponents
especially in this type of chevium
chevening guns or nigh dwarfs whenever
opponents uh there is a chance for e5s
and d5s you have to be very very careful
about it
all right i think this is a good
stopping point i've left you with a lot
of questions something else some i
answered some i didn't i have more
chaveningen that we will go over next
week mainly for knight d7 rather than
knight c6
and we're going to take a short
break do a switch to twitch and we'll be
back with you in
a little bit of time to analyze your
games so
have them ready
link on leach us and i'll see you there
in a minute
happy thanksgiving
[Music]
you